and a woman is dead tonight after what
police are calling a targeted home
robbery in the southwest valley it was
not too far from jones and robindale two
nearby schools went on lockdown because
of it sasha lofta spoke with police and
people who live in that area she joins
us now live with the latest
denise it's been quite a while since it
had this happened this afternoon you can
see behind me there still are police on
scene as they continue to investigate
this situation they tell us this
targeted robbery led to a shootout and a
car chase and what many are calling a
normally quiet neighborhood
it's sad and scary john baxter says he's
scared and pretty shocked to see someone
shot and killed in his southwest valley
neighborhood my wife had called me
earlier
saying that there was cops galore around
this neighborhood his son's school was
one of two campuses put on lockdown as
flashing lights and crime scene tape
took over his street friday
officers say a woman is dead after a
robbery that led to a shootout in her
home i do want to stress that this is
not a random
robbery lieutenant ray spencer with
metro police tells us the three men
involved were leaving after it happened
when the woman's boyfriend was coming
home from the store he chased them
ramming their car into a wall the
suspects then dumped it and took off
it's terrifying to picture this right in
your backyard but lieutenant spencer
says those in the area should know this
was targeted and wouldn't have happened
just anywhere there's some
security in that aspect it's not like
someone just happened to show up at this
house regardless baxter isn't happy to
see this kind of thing so close
and he's doing everything he can to make
sure his family is safe just make sure
all my doors and windows are locked
police say there was a third person
living in the home she was home when the
shooting happened but is ok now all
three suspects according to police
involved here are still on the run
tonight if you have any information you
are asked to call crime stoppers and of
course you can remain anonymous
reporting live tonight sasha loftis live
local now